solana rhodes just rug pulled her nft
project and ran away with 1.5 million
dollars now she's claiming it's not her
fault her community was just getting too
negative for her one of those negative
comments was about how this person can't
feed their kids because they invested it
all into a star's jpeg collection quote
i spent what i can't lose spent 4k no
job have a two-year-old son if only
someone bought my christmas lana yeah
and apparently lana road saw this post
and said hey this is this is getting way
too negative for me i'm out i didn't
know these people wanted to feed their
kids apparently she's too busy feeding
her own kid to worry about this when
asked about this she said yo diapers are
expensive that's right guys she needs
that 1.5 million dollars now let's just
say what this is from lana rhodes to the
to the person who invests their last
diamond to it this is the dumbest story
we've ever talked about by far i mean
it's there's no contest but here we are
so let's just let's just embrace what it
is welcome to the 10 million dollar
studio i'm your host coffee zilla the
internet detective
so again this story is what it seems a
star gone influencer offered an
investment to her fans and then they
invested 1.5 million dollars she ran
away with the money i'm gonna say right
off the top come real close come here we
have to have a talk okay if you fell for
this we're in trouble you're this is not
good now to be clear she's wrong for
doing this i want the best for you guys
and i'm sorry that you got scammed but
it's looking bleak if you fell for this
this was not a hard one to spot this was
not a big gotcha but anyways with that
disclaimer out of the way let's talk
about the story okay so look lana rhodes
started an nft project full of a bunch
of pictures of basically cartoon
versions of herself and she told people
she was gonna work super hard to
basically make this a valuable
investment the nft project was called
cryptosis and she said my number one
goal for the project is to increase the
value of crypto cis nfts and make it a
lucrative investment for holders that
they can sell for more than they paid to
mint and this is basically my big beef
with this project they made it sound
like an investment nowhere was it like
hey buy my art clearly this was
something where it was like no you're
gonna make money on this project and she
repeats this idea later she says quote
the brand plus value will keep growing
with every drop so her fans thought this
was going to be some kind of long-term
investment i guess and of course it
wasn't if you look at her road map it
was pretty clear things were promised
that weren't delivered on for example in
phase two she said decentraland and
sandbox wearable will start getting
developed she promised a piece of
designated metaverse land would be
purchased to create a hangout spot she
said 50 lucky cryptocyst owners will
receive cryptosis merch signed by lana
even promising to distribute 5 eth to
the top holders and of course one of the
biggest things was an exclusive
community to speak with lana this
apparently was their reasoning for
having to raise so much money 1.5
million dollars precisely because they
weren't a pump and dump
unlike other pump and dump projects
we don't just plan on stopping after
minting so we actually have to be able
to fund all that stuff so you heard it
right there this is a long-term project
not a pump and dump but that didn't
happen less than a week after all this
money was raised lana rhodes vanished
from her community and took the money
out of the wallet here's the main wallet
withdrawing over 1.5 million dollars in
ethereum out of the project her reason
things got too negative quote the truth
as why lana hasn't been around was she
was very shocked and upset by the amount
of negative and rude comments she was
seeing in the chat i personally find
this part hilarious because i i checked
out this discord you can't imagine a
bigger simp army these guys were not
negative and i do mean guys by the way
uh they put their last dollar into this
project truth be told and one of them
even got like a tattoo of the project
logo on them before it rugged but my
point sort of is this wasn't a negative
community at all in fact even after they
had been scammed all these people in the
community tried to police each other
into being nice so that lana would come
back here's one of the holders saying
how do you want us to keep it respectful
while the whole entire management
scammed 6 000 people and took their
money and left and then the person
responds doesn't mean you can't be
respectful
i mean i feel like that tells you
everything you need to know they had
just been scammed and still you have
people in the chat being like hey be
respectful about it and honestly they
used this fact that people were upset
that they uh basically got rug pulled to
justify then abandoning the project
here's actually one of the collaborators
informing the community of this they
said good morning i chatted to crypto
cis about my nft
lana isn't interested in continuing
mainly because she felt part of her
discord community was cruel and she
didn't want to have to look at comments
that's right guys lana rhodes doesn't
want to have to look at cruel comments
just because you can't feed your kids
now doesn't mean it's okay for you to
get negative on her oh by the way yeah
that same post that collaborator um they
actually said they'd be releasing their
own nft project in the same sentence so
they basically said you guys got scammed
and so uh look out for nft scam part two
and you might be thinking who would fall
for this well the same people who bought
the first one uh because look here they
said quote go show her some love talking
about this person let's prove we are not
toxic she can still save us
i mean at this point it's pretty sad
isn't it you got rug pulled and you're
about to go into a second rug pull
i mean again i want to help you guys but
there's only so much i can do if
you're gonna do that you know what i
mean there's only so much we can do so
yeah that's basically the story uh what
did we learn from this hopefully nothing
um i hopefully all of this was obvious
to you if it wasn't you need to pump the
stock honestly zilla hey it's free
you're not gonna get rugged this time
it's impossible just like and subscribe
it's absolutely free and you need to
watch a lot more of this channel